bonjour claude lise bonjour vous êtes le
secrétaire général du rassemblement
démocratique pour la martinique 1ère
diem qui étaient en séminaire ce
week-end au carbet un séminaire qui a
permis à votre mouvement politique de
retrouver des couleurs
écoutez il s'agit d'un séminaire
organisé par deux sections faut pas non
plus qu'on donne à ce séminaire une
dimension quand même n'avait pas comment
le section importante quand même de 40
et de saint-pierre et je tiens à
préciser que ce séminaire était prévue
bien avant oui mais si les abeilles
matin on va le tirer
on veut les rattache il y a eu
effectivement ces incidents lors de la
dernière plénière à l'assemblée de de
martinique une ambiance détestable au
sein de la majorité au pouvoir
montplaisir qui se veut loyal mais qui
souligne que marie jeanne les
insuffisances de l'action politique de
l'assemblée vous qui remettait le même
mon plaisir à sa place marie jeanne et
ni leur divorce prononcé
et vous qui bat qui dès le début
dénonciez les liens plutôt trouble entre
l'assemblée et l'exécutif
à part ça à part ça je n'ai que cette le
séminaire comme ça ah non non je n'ai
pas dit que qu'on n'a pas abordé les
sujets importants mais je veux bien dire
qu'il s'agissait d'une réunion qui était
prévue bien avant
et parmi les trois mâts de l'union ce
maxi sonore du laser au sein d'ensembles
berne a donné l'occasion de prendre le
pouls d'une partie de nos militants mais
j'en ai rencontré d'autres ailleurs
il y aura d'autres réunions mais je peux
vous dire que les militants et adm sont
outrés outré des attaques d'abord dans
leur secrétaire général fait l'objet
sont indignés et ils me disent que il
faut maintenant que l'on marque une
sorte de
deux dards et qu' il y a une limite
une sorte de deux lignes rouges qui est
maintenant à tête et qu'il ne faut pas
laisser dépasser alors la liste
qu'est-ce qu'on sache est fermé alors ce
n'était des distances de tir et
visionnaire mais jeudi bien que ce ce
cette ambiance que que j'ai ressenti ce
climat que j'ai ressenti
je lance un également partout dans la
population les gens en ont assez
assez des excès du président du conseil
exécutif de la ctm on a toujours connu
avec un tempérament excessif tout le
monde relativisait jusqu alors ses
propos mais là maintenant ça prend une
dimension qui est devenu insupportable
et c'est d'autant plus insupportable que
en réalité il est soutenu dans dans ce
genre de propos par d'autres élus que je
trouve encore plus coupable que lui
c'est à dire ils sont plus coupables car
ils n'ont pas vraiment et assurent ces
élus ils n'ont pas les sens et c'est
surtout ça qu'on vous les connaissez
très bien gérée par les en avait
interviewé récemment partis qui
soutiennent des situations insoutenables
je le redis et ils n'ont pas l'excusé
d'aborder le tempérament auquel nous
sommes habitués
concernant le président du conseil
exécutif
par conséquent moi j'estime qu'ils sont
coupables de le pousser à aller de plus
en plus loin dans un comportement
inadmissible qu'en fait j'ai vu assez de
comploteurs de complot no no no no no de
celui qui a l'obsession des complots
c'est par mois et tout le monde tout le
monde a constaté qu'il y avait une sorte
de syndrome obsessionnel au niveau de
l'exécutif
il doit répondre avec eux vous divulguer
ce mélange dit ce qui est la réalité ils
voient des complots partout
bon donc je pense que ça suffit car il
s'agit du personnage politique qui
détient le plus de pouvoirs à la matinée
du fait de la loi de juillet 2011 que
j'ai toujours critiquer
à créer une situation hyper présidence à
la matinée du fait de cette loi
et en plus du fait de l'application de
cette loi telle qu'elle est appliquée
elle à ces insuffisances mais
l'application se fait en aggravant les
tout ce qu'il y a de ligue hâtive dans
cette loi sadique ont abouti à une
situation où il n'est plus possible
d'émettre une critique
il devra aussi d'émettre une observation
dès que vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur un
détail sur une virgule vous est voué aux
gémonies vous êtes dans un complot donc
c'est devenu un fonctionnement
antidémocratique mais vraiment que comme
on ne l'a jamais connue alors te disent
vous avez vraiment besoin d'organiser un
séminaire d'aller prendre le pouls de
vos sympathisants de vos militants
organisent ce soir vous avez besoin de
faire ce séminaire nous savons et en
ligne rouge que vous n'allez plus
accéder en europe mais un dirigeant
politique qui prend régulièrement le
pouls de ses militants il se trouve que
damien c'est ce séminaire s'est situé
quelques temps razel calendrier mais les
problèmes mais bien entendu mais je vais
ziqi li à d'autres réunions qui se
tiennent d'ailleurs d'accord nous avons
des réunions régulier à notre siège mais
ce que je constate c'est l'unanimité de
nos militants très bien qui regrette que
ce que leurs positions rejoignent les
positions que j'entends de la cie très
grande majorité des six chorales et
comment ça va ce comment ça va se
traduire le fait que la ligne rouge ne
peut plus nos trois plus d'être franchie
comment vous allez le faire mais avait
dû président du conseil du stif que vous
avez nommés vis-à-vis de ceux et celles
qui le pousserait selon vous c'est bien
écoutez je vais vous répondre
un peu comme monsieur mâcon a répondu
quand on lui a dit qu'effectivement la
baguette situation
et nous a dit prenez vos responsabilités
c'est à dire mais c'est ce que je dis à
tous les élus chacun doit point de ses
responsables mais ça veut rien dire ça
mais sur la totalité avait bien entendu
mais bien entendu parce qu'on a eu des
occasions on a tout tenté pour pour le
simple fait de savoir à sion devait
recevoir des mondes du personnel qui
voulait parler à l'assemblée vous avez
vu qu'il ya des gens qui ont cédé à des
pressions
il ya des gens qui ont voté contre et
puis qui sont venus me dire après
heureusement que leur miel à passer
alors on raconte dans notre office de
savoir qu'il ya des jointures peur de
prendre leurs responsabilités à partir
de maintenant vous président de
l'assemblée de martinique secrétaire
générale du rdr
renforcé par ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end un séminaire au carbet comment
vous allez traduire cette ligne rouge
qu'il ne faut plus des près ce que vous
allez dire alfred marie-jeanne et à ceux
qui le soutiennent
ça suffit mais mais mais ça fait
longtemps que je dis c'est bien mais ça
fait longtemps jeu je peux vous dire je
suis même j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
vous de vous dire que j'ai demandé que
les choses changent
il était question d'un séminaire tient
de réflexion ça fait deux ans qu'on nous
promet un séminaire pour essayer de
faire évoluer le mode de fonctionnement
de la cdm
mais c'est devenu l'arlésienne alors
aujourd'hui de croître comme risoul
vendredi sont plus clairement plus
ouvertement ce que nous disons depuis
déjà des mois et des mois révolus
mavericks rencontre avec le président
exécutif je lui ai dit un certain nombre
de choses qui vont dans le sens de
propositions de partenariat écoutez nous
avions signé nous évader m
tout le monde a déjà nouvelle a dit le
texte du 27 janvier 2015 qui disait que
nous devions appliquer le programme en
partenariat c'est écrit là et ça a été
considérée comme comme un chiffon de
papier alors jusqu'en 2010 et atteint 2
boisset hôtel de ses amis que j'entends
certaines ses lieutenants faux semblant
d'oublier que cet accord politique a
préexisté à ce qu'on appelle accord de
gestion avec le goût qu'on voulait pas
me répondre et de l'adour voulais pas me
répéter
ces 13 cas face au délire verbal moi je
la porte des faits des voyages et des
documents ouais moi je ne viens pas me
lancer dans la polémique
raconter n'importe quoi j'ai des
dossiers qui appuie tout cas ce que
j'avance qu'elles disent jeudi dernier
il ya eu de la visite présidentielle
emmanuel macron qui au morne-rouge a
quand même livré une scène un peu
ubuesque de ce qui se passe en
martinique de côté le conseiller
exécutif louis bouderait de l'autre un
élu de l'assemblée de martinique
jean-philippe eux ni leurs également
député le président qui leur dit mais
bon tu as ces vautours d'une table et
discuter avec mes portraits de van de
ven des doléances de la profession
agricole qui disait mais les dossiers
sont bloqués mais non mais mais mais ce
n'est qu'une manifestation d'une
situation qui devient insupportable ce
n'est que le symptôme de ce que je
dénonce vous aurez de plus en plus cela
puisque l'information sur six civils au
terme
l'information ne circule pas normalement
c'est à lui que tout est décidé par un
petit groupe qui est pratiquement
concentré au sein de l'exécutif est en
réalité tout est décidé par une seule
personne c'est ça la réalité
vous avez une assemblée qui normalement
de par la loi devrait contrôler
l'exécutif qui en réalité devenu une
chambre d'enregistrement
c'est ça la réalité elle a moins de
moyens que le conseil consultatif qui a
été mis en place
c'est à dire que la loi a formellement
prévu les moyens donnés aux conseil
consultatif en matière de personnel et
de budget mais n'a rien prévu pour nous
dans l'esprit de la loi
c'est que l'assemblée minimum de moyens
mais comme ce n'est pas écrit et bien on
en a pas alors d'alerter sur sa fiche de
l'état nous dit est ce que l'état nous
dit bien là aussi écouter débrouillez
vous prenez vos responsabilités voilà on
n'est même pas à mi parcours du mandat
ce sera loin 3 encore 3,8 et écoutez je
pense que chaque élu va maintenant avoir
à coeur d'assumer ses responsabilités
car il y a des responsabilités face à
une population qui constate que les
choses ne vont pas alors je ne suis pas
de ceux qui disent que nous ne faisons
rien
ce n'est pas le cas on a appris qu'un
programme on pourrait aller plus vite
plus loin plus fort et c'est ce que les
gens attendent mais pour ce traître du
partenariat
il faut de la solidarité il faut cesser
ce système hyper concentration de
pouvoir si claude lise secrétaire
générale du rdr merci